Çeviri: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Caymazer
Emin Çapa
Gazeteci
Bugün Türkiye'de ve
dünyadaki en büyük sorun,
şahsi kanaatime göre,
insanın akıl ve bilimden sapması, evet.
Ama aynı zamanda vicdanını kaybetmesi.
Bugün bu çok büyük
bir sorun hâline geliyor.
Çünkü Lewis Carroll'u
hepiniz biliyorsunuz,
Alice Harikalar Diyarında'nın yazarıdır.
Onun böyle bir sözü var:
''Bu dünyadaki yerim ne?
Ah, büyük muamma işte budur.''
Bugün kaybedilen şeylerden biri bence bu.
Hepimizin ne yazık ki
büyük oranda kaybettiği bir şey.
Bütün toplum, sadece Türkiye'de değil.
Türkiye'de çok açık bir şekilde
çok büyük oranda.
Ama ben size kısa bir
hikâye anlatmak istiyorum.
Aslında sizin hikâyeniz bu,
hepimizin hikâyesi.
Evrenin yaklaşık olarak
13,5 milyar yıl önce
ya da 13,8 milyar yıl önce
başladığını düşünüyoruz.
Bize öyle söylüyor bilim insanları.
4,5 milyar yıl önce de
Güneş Sistemi ve Dünya ortaya çıktı.
3,8 milyar yıl önce,
3,8 milyar yıl önce de
dünyada ilk yaşam başladı.
80 milyon yıl önce Meksika
Körfezi'ne bir göktaşı düştü.
Ve 350 milyon yıl boyunca
dünyaya hükmeden
dinozorların devrini bitirdi.
Eğer o zamanlar bir uzaylı gelseydi ve
dünyaya kim hâkim olacak diye baksaydı,
dinozorları bulurdu, onları düşünürdü.
Çünkü en küçüğünden
dev boyutlarına kadar,
otçulundan etçiline kadar,
tamamen dünyanın
imparatorlarıydı dinozorlar.
Ama bu göktaşı Meksika
Körfezi'ne çarptı ve
canlıların %90'ı kadarını
türlerin, tamamen yok etti.
Memelilerin çağı başladı.
55 milyon yıl önce de
ilk primatlar ortaya çıktı.
Beş milyon yıl önce ilk insansı,
ardından 1,8 milyon yıl önce
ilk insan ortaya çıktı.
Şurada gördüğünüz Lucy, adı Lucy onun.
Canlandırılmış hâli olarak.
200 bin yıl önce de Homo Sapiens.
Descartes'in hani ''düşünüyorum,
öyleyse varım''ı uyarladığı,
düşündüğünün üstüne
düşünebilen insan, you know?
Yani ''Homo sapiens sapiens''.
Biz sadece ''Homo sapiens''
diyoruz biliyorsunuz.
200 bin yıl önce çıktı.
Bu Arjantin'de Eller Mağarası
dediğimiz bir şey.
30 küsur bin yıl önce
içinde binlerce el var.
Niye onu yaptılar bilmiyoruz.
Belki insan hani ben de yaşadım
demek ister ya.
Belki de ben de buradaydım
demek için yaptılar.
Niyesini bilmiyoruz,
ama 30 bin yıl önce
mağara duvarlarına ellerini bu şekilde
boyayan insanlar vardı.
Ve 70 bin yıl önce insan dediğimiz canlı,
kültür dediğimiz yapıları ortaya çıkardı.
10 bin yıl önce de buz devri bitti
ve tarım başladı.
Tarım devrimi dediğimiz şey başladı.
O güne kadar ortalama insan ömrü
18 ila 20 yıl kadardı.
İnsan hükmettiği enerji 1 beygir gücü
deriz ya standart odur,
bunun beşte biri, yani
insanın kas gücü kadar.
Öldükten sonra sizin yaşadığınızın
hiçbir kanıtı kalmazdı.
Sizi tanıyanlar öldüğü anda,
siz bu dünyaya hiç gelmemiş
gibi olurdunuz.
Ve bütün servetiniz yanınızda
taşıyabildiğiniz kadardı.
Atalarımız çünkü avcı ve toplayıcıydı.
Ama tarım devrimi ortalama ömrü
30 yıla çıkardı.
Sonra insanın hükmettiği enerji
1 beygir gücüne geldi ortalamada.
Çünkü hayvanlar evcilleştirildi.
Kral, imparator ya da sanatçıysan
kimse seni unutmazdı.
Kendi adına anıtlar, tablolar,
tabletlerde bir yazılar olurdu.
Servet de arazi, hayvan
ve bu çok önemli köle.
Yani siz ve ben.
Birilerinin kölesi.
Sanayi devrimi ise ortalama ömrü
1900'de insan hayatının
en uzun olduğu döneme,
49 yıla, bakın 49 yıl.
Hani İlyada’da falan yaşlı adam
falan deniyor ya,
onlar 30 yaşları civarındalar
biliyor musunuz?
Uzun ömürlü, çok yaşamış çünkü.
İnsanın hükmettiği enerji ise
yüzlerce beygir gücüne ulaştı.
Sonra servet, ürettiğiniz mal
ve kontrol ettiğiniz sermayeye döndü
sanayi devrimiyle.
Tren ve otomobil, hareketliliği
insanın çağlar boyunca
hayal edemediği bir noktaya getirdi.
İnsanı hareketli hâle getirdi
buhar gücünün izniyle.
Şimdi içinde bulunduğumuz yerse,
yani yeni bilim çağı dediğimiz
bilim çağıysa ortalama ömrünü
insanın, bilmiyoruz.
Şu anda biz insanın ortalama ömrü
nereye gidiyor bu çağda,
birazdan size izlettireceğim
bir videoyla, bilmiyoruz.
İnsan, insan olma vasfının
sınırlarına gelmiş vaziyette.
İnsanın hükmettiği enerji
trilyonlarca beygir gücüne ulaştı.
Bu ne demek?
Bu şu demek.
Nükleer güç de dâhil olmak üzere,
çok büyük bir gücü
kontrol altında tutuyoruz.
Ve kendimizi tehdit ediyoruz bu güçle.
Ve bütün servet bugün,
üretilen bilgiye ait bir şey.
Bilgi üretmeyenlerin başarılı bir
geleceği olması mümkün değil.
Bu yüzden bilgi üreten toplumları
hepimiz hayranlıkla izliyoruz
ve onların peşinden gidiyoruz.
Neyi kastediyorum?
Bildiğiniz insanın
sonu geliyor arkadaşlar.
Çok güzel bir kitap var
''Geleceğin Fiziği'' diye.
Kaku'nun kitabı.
Asya asıllı Amerikalı kendisi.
Türkiye'ye de iki kez geldi.
Hepiniz lütfen kitabı bulun ve okuyun.
Her sıradan insanın anlayabileceği kadar.
Yani ben anladıysam siz rahatça
anlarsınız öyle düşünün.
O kadar basit bir dille gelecek
nasıl olacak bunu anlatıyor.
Ve orada şöyle bir şey var.
''Biz'' diyor, ''doğal yollarla ölen
son insanlar olacağız.''
Neyi kastediyoruz?
Organ basımının üç boyutlu yazıcıda,
organ basımının sınırındayız şu anda.
Birtakım organlar basılıyor ve üretiliyor
ve bunlar maksimum on yıl içinde
insanlara nakledilmeye başlanacak.
Mesela Çin'de ilk nakil yapıldı.
Tam olarak bu değil ama şöyle bir şey.
Bir çocuğun omurunda bir sorun var.
Omur çıkarıldı.
Sonra üç boyutlu tarayıcıda tarandı,
bilgisayara aktarıldı.
Omurdaki eğrilik bilgisayarda düzeltildi.
Kalçasından alınan jelle üretildi
ve çocuğa tekrar takıldı.
Evet, kemik ölü bir doku sonuçta.
Ama ilk insana ilk nakilde
üç boyutlu yazıcıdan, o oldu.
Dolayısıyla çok insanın insan olma vasfını
sorguladığımız bir yerdeyiz.
Buna dair bir videomuz var.
Beraber izleyelim,
sonrasında devam edelim.
(Video kaydı)
Ve sonunda tüm işlevleri yerine
getiren bir organ üretildi.
İskoçya'da çalışan araştırmacılar
laboratuvarda büyüttükleri hücreleri
tamamen fonksiyonel bir organa dönüştürüp
canlı bir hayvana nakletmeyi başardı.
Edinburgh Üniversitesi Yenileyici Tıp
Merkezi'ndeki araştırmacılar
bu tekniğin ileride insanlar için de
kullanılacağını düşünüyor.
Emin Çapa: Buna ne deniyor?
Buna biofabrikasyon deniyor.
Bu sözcük İngilizce sözlüğe
geçen yıl girdi.
Üç boyutlu yazıcıda sizin kök
hücrelerinizi alıyoruz ve çoğaltıyoruz.
Kök hücre bilmiyorum biliyor musunuz?
Göz hücreniz göz hücresi,
işte cilt hücreniz cilt hücresi,
beyin hücreniz, karaciğer hücreniz,
tamamen organ.
Ama kök hücre bunların hepsine
dönüştürülebilen bir hücre.
Ve ilk kez 2014 yılının
Kasım ayının 3. Haftasında,
bir Türk bilim insanın başında olduğu,
Harvard Tıp Fakültesi'nden bir ekip
İskoçya'daki bu laboratuvarda
üç boyutlu yazıcıda
kök hücreyi çoğalttılar.
Kök hücreyi çoğalttılar arkadaşlar
üç boyutlu yazıcıda.
Bu yüzden insanın insan olma
vasfının değiştiği
dememin nedeni bu.
Çok önemli, çok kritik bir insan eşiğinin
aşıldığı bir yerdeyiz.
İkinci bir şey daha oluyor.
İnsanın mahremiyetinin sonuna geliyoruz.
Bu salondaki hiç kimse yanındaki
kimseyi tam olarak,
yüzde yüz bir şekilde tanıyamaz
ve bilemez.
Hepimizin bir takım zihninin arkasında
düşünceleri var,
söylemedikleri var, gizli bir hayatı var.
Ama insanın bu mahremiyetini
elinden alabilecek bir sınırdayız.
O da insan düşüncesini,
sizin düşüncenizi,
sizin hayal ettiğiniz bir şeyi,
bilgisayarda başkalarına
izlettirebilme imkânınız
ya da belki zorla izleme
imkânının eşiğindeyiz.
Benim için bu da çok kritik
önemde bir şey.
Buna ilişkin bir videomuz var.
İsterseniz bir de onu seyredin
ve devam edelim.
(Video kaydı)
İsviçrelilere yakışacak bir yalınlıkla
insan beyni projesi olarak adlandırılan
bu çalışmayla,
insan beyninin ilk eksiksiz
bilgisayar simülasyonu yaratılacak.
Hedef 10 yıl içinde beynin biyolojisine
dair her şeyi modellemek.
Mühendisler, veri kuramcıları,
sinir bilimciler, biyologlar,
evrim uzmanları gibi birçok alandan uzman,
bu disiplinler arası projede çalışıyor.
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri ise
bir başka dev proje başlattı.
''Beyin Girişimi'' denen bu projeyle
ilk kez insanın tüm beyin etkinliklerinin
ayrıntılı haritası çıkarılacak.
Böylece bir anının oluşma
anı görüntülenecek
ve bu anı da daha sonra
bilgisayarda izlenebilecek.
Çalışmanın bir diğer amacı ise
beynin davranış bozukluğuna neden olan
yanlarını bulup bunları düzeltebilmek.
Penn Eyalet Üniversitesi'nin
başını çektiği
ve sekiz kurumun rol aldığı
bir başka proje ise,
beynin görsel korteksini bilgisayarda
canlandırmayı hedefliyor.
Beş yıl içinde insan beyninin gördüğü
ya da hayal ettiği görüntüleri
bilgisayara aktarmayı umuyor
bilim insanları.
EÇ: İşte bu da olayın,
bilimin iki taraflı yanı.
Bir yanda çok büyük bir tehlike,
bir yanda çok özel bir şey var.
Ve bu, insan ömrünü uzatan
o organ nakliyle birlikte
geleceğin en önemli
şekillendiricilerinden biri olacak.
Şu anda dünyada iki büyük dalga var.
Bir tanesi benim asıl işime dair,
ekonomi tarafına dair.
O dalga son beş yüzyıla egemen
olan batılı güçlerin
ekonomik üstünlüklerini dünyaya,
dünya haritasını şekillendirme güçlerini,
onların elinden alan ekonomik güç dalgası.
Gücün önemli bir kısmı
Atlantik'ten Pasifik'e kayıyor.
Yani yukarıda Amerika, Kanada,
aşağıda Brezilya, Arjantin,
Şili'nin olduğu.
Öbür tarafta da yukarıda,
belki biraz Rusya,
ama Kore, Japonya, Çin.
Aşağısında Singapur, Hong Kong,
Endonezya, Malezya,
Avustralya'nın olduğu
Pasifik'e kayıyor güç.
Bu orta vadenin şekillendiricisi.
Ama asıl şekillendirici olan
bu bilimsel patlama.
Neden bu kadar çok bilim
patlaması yaşanıyor
diye bir kendinize sorun.
Şu anda bilimde gerçek bir
patlama yaşanıyor.
Ve bu bilimsel patlamanın
dışında kalan
herkes ama herkes, her toplum,
sanayi devrimini
ve matbaayı kaçıranlar gibi,
çağın çok ötesine düşecekler.
Ben sadece bu kaygı ve bu korkuyla
ekonominin yanında
bilim programı yapıyorum.
İnsanlar dalga geçiyorlar.
Sen ne anlarsın bilmem ne.
Birisi yapsın. Biri bunu yapmalı.
Çünkü bu ülke eğer bilim ve aklın
bu kadar dışında kalmaya devam ederse
bundan 20 yıl sonra, 30 yıl sonra
çok daha kötü bir yerde olacak.
Neden böyle diyorum?
Bir şeyden.
İnsanoğlunun bir sorunu var.
Evrenin bize ait olduğunu düşünüyoruz.
Bütün noktaları birleştiriyoruz
ve evrenin merkezi neresi
biliyor musunuz?
Tam benim durduğum yer.
Niye?
Çünkü ben buradayım. Değil mi?
Ben burada olduğuma göre
evrenin merkezi burası.
Çünkü evrendeki en önemli canlı,
en önemli varlık benim.
İnsanoğlu böyle düşünüyor.
Ama öyle değil.
Şimdi size bir şey seyrettirmek istiyorum.
(Video kaydı)
Uzayda hava olmadığı için
herkes ses de olmayacağını düşünür.
Çünkü sesin iletilebilmesi için
havaya ihtiyaç vardır.
Ancak aslında tam da öyle değil.
Kulağımız sesleri duymasa da
aletlerimiz sesleri kaydedebilir.
İşte NASA tam da böyle yapıyor.
Uyduların özel dizayn edilmiş aletleriyle
gezegenlerin sesleri kayıt ediliyor.
(Ses)
Bu duyduğunuz Satürn'ün halkalarının sesi.
Bu güneş sisteminin en büyük
gezegeni Jüpiter'in sesi.
(Ses)
İşte üzerinde yaşadığımız dünyamızın
uzaydan duyulan sesi.
Ya da şiirsel deyişiyle evimiz dünyanın
uzaya haykırdığı şarkısı.
(Ses)
EÇ: Canlıymış gibi geldi mi?
Sanki canlıymış ve insan
gibi konuşmuyormuş ama
konuşuyormuş gibi değil mi?
Çünkü dünya aynı zamanda
çok büyük bir sıvı kütlesine sahip.
O, bu sesi çıkartıyor.
Evrene baktığınız zaman
biz üstün insanlar
ve keşfedilmeyi bekleyen zavallı şeyler...
gibi düşünebilirsiniz.
Ama öyle değil.
Neden?
Çünkü kendimize sormamız
gereken şey bu.
Ben kimim?
Biz kimiz?
Ve evrenin içerisinde neyiz acaba?
Bu soruyu sormadığımız zaman
insanlığımızı kaybediyoruz.
Neden?
Bu demin gördüğünüz şey.
Bu Voyager 1.
Bir kahraman.
Bütün bugünkü uzay çalışmalarının
şekillendiricisi.
Bu Voyager 1 çok enteresan.
Benim hayatımda da özel bir yeri var.
5 Eylül 1977'de fırlatıldı.
Güneş sisteminin dışına çıkan
ilk insan yapısı araç.
Güneş sisteminin dışına çıktı.
Bu Jüpiter'in yanından geçerken
gönderdiği fotoğraf.
Hayatınızda bu kadar güzel bir görüntü
gördünüz mü bilmiyorum.
Bu kadar güzel bir tabloyu
hiçbir insan yapmadı.
O yukarıda gördüğünüz kızıl leke,
600 yıldır devam eden bir fırtına.
Hiç kenarlarına değmeden içinden
geçebileceği kadar dünyanın
büyük bir fırtına o.
Ama onu meşhur eden bu değil.
Yıldızlar arası boşluğa çıktığında
bize bir şey gönderdi.
İlk kez güneşin bozmadığı
yıldızların sesini gönderdi.
İnsan evladı artık yıldızların sesinin
nasıl olduğunu biliyor.
Ve ben de size bunu dinletmek istiyorum.
(Video kaydı) (Ses)
EÇ: 14 Şubat 1990'da insanoğluna
bir ayna tuttu.
Kim olduğunu, haddini bildiren bir ayna.
Dünyanın 6 milyar 86 milyon
176 bin 360 kilometre
uzaktan fotoğrafını gönderdi.
Düşünürler o fotoğraf için
''tabu yıkıcı'' dediler.
Bilim insanları ''zihin açıcı'' dediler.
Ve Carl Sagan kısacık bir video yaptı.
Ve ''Soluk Mavi Nokta'' diye.
Bize o aynayı gösterdi.
O fotoğraf bu.
Satürn'ün halkalarından siz, biz,
''mühim insanların'' yaşadığı
dünyanın fotoğrafı.
Şurada gördüğünüz o toz
zerresinin içindesiniz.
Bir hiçin içindesiniz aslında.
Bütün evren sizin çevrenizde dönüyor.
Bütün evren benim çevremde dönüyor.
Bu kadar önemliyim.
Ama evren açısından ben değil.
Yaşadığın dünya bile bir toz zerresi.
Şimdi şu Carl Sagan'ın videosunu
kısacık bir şey bir dinleyin.
Ve onun sonunda ben size
birkaç cümle etmek istiyorum.
(Video kaydı)
EÇ: Buradaki en önemli cümle
ne biliyor musunuz?
Yardım için ipucu,
bizi kendimizden kurtarmak
için yardım ipucu,
başka hiçbir yerden gelmeyecek.
Sağınıza ya da solunuza bakın.
Şikâyet ettiğiniz sevgilinizi, karınızı,
kocanızı, annenizi, babanızı,
işinizi, ülkenizi, dünyayı düşünün.
Yardım için ipucu başka hiçbir
yerden gelmeyecek.
Sadece sizden gelebilir.
Kurtarmak için.
Bu çok önemli bir soru.
Ve son olarak gene aynı yere
dönmek istiyorum.
Bir gün insan kendine bunu sorar.
Herkes kendine sorar.
İnsan nedir?
İnsan sadece bir suret midir?
''Sadece şu şekilde olduğum için mi
insanım ben?'' diye kendimize sorarız.
Hayır değil.
İnsan akıl ve vicdanın bir karması.
Sadece akıl bizi robot yapar.
Sadece vicdan da saftirik yapar.
İkisinin birleşmesi lazım.
Bugünün önemli sorunu akıl yolunda,
belki bizim ülkemiz değil ama
dünya hızla koşuyor.
Ama vicdan tarafında büyük bir kayıp var.
Hayatınız sadece size mi aittir?
Annenizin, babanızın,
doğmamış çocuğunuzun,
eski sevgilinizin, sokaktaki aç kedilerin,
susuz köpeklerin, uçan kuşların.
Siz iyi bir hayat yaşayın diye
ısıttığınız dünya yüzünden
yaşam alanlarını kaybeden kutup ayılarının
sizin hayatınız benim hayatım üzerinde
hiç mi hakkı yoktur?
Eğer yoktur diyorsanız,
onlara karşı bir sorumluluğum
yoktur diyorsanız,
o zaman tamam.
Ama vardır diyorsanız bir gün
siz de benim gibi,
ben hemen her gün kendime
bunu sorarım,
bir gün insanoğlu diz çöker ve şöyle der,
''Bu dünyadaki yerim ne?''
"Ben ne yapıyorum ya?"
"Ben kimim?"
"Ben sadece para kazanmak
için çalışan biri miyim?"
Lüks markalar giymek için,
ev, araba, yazlıklar almak için mi
bu dünyadayım derseniz
ve eğer yanıt sadece buysa,
ister süperstar olun,
ister dünyanın en güçlü adamı olun,
bir gün hayatınız biter
ve bu soruyla baş başa kalır
ve belki de bence pişman olursunuz.
Ben o yüzden size bugün
sadece insanın akıl,
sadece akıl olmadığını
bir hatırlatmak istedim.
Çünkü hem Türkiye'de hem dünyada
bu vicdanın kaybı,
bence bugünün en önemli
sorunlarından biri.
Teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz için.
Umarım sıkılmadınız.
Sağ olun.
( Alkış)